[Música]
y
en españa tras detectarse varios rebotes
importantes de kobe 19 en prostíbulos
algunas comunidades autónomas decidieron
ordenar su cierre para evitar la
propagación de este virus que ya afecta
mucho a españa
se trata de aquí de cataluña de también
la comunidad autónoma de castilla la
mancha en el centro del país y de la
comunidad de madrid' lastres acumulando
un porcentaje muy importante de los
1.600 prostíbulos que hay en españa se
dieron cuenta de que pues la situación
era muy complicada en estos centros ya
que al detectarse el caso era casi
imposible rastrear a los clientes
identificarlos para que se hagan en las
pruebas pcr esto también lo reconoció la
ministra de igualdad y viene en montego
y la ministra pide a partir de agua a
todas las autonomías cerrar estos clubes
alternas al considerar que la salud y
los
derechos de las mujeres eran
fundamentales
[Música]
una de las actividades que no ha tenido
freno desde el inicio de la pandemia de
kobe es el sexoservicio esto es
especialmente notorio en puntos como la
frontera norte concretamente en tijuana
donde de acuerdo con medios locales las
trabajadoras sexuales han seguido viendo
a sus clientes mayoritariamente
estadounidenses esto a pesar del cierre
de centros nocturnos y de la restricción
al tránsito fronterizo lo mismo ocurre
en la frontera sur en tapachula chiapas
punto de tránsito de miles de
centroamericanos aquí en la ciudad de
mexico durante la cuarentena el gobierno
capitalino distribuyó tarjetas de apoyo
económico entre sexoservidoras y ahora
que se han reabierto los hoteles de paso
han establecido estrictos protocolos
como filtros sanitarios en los accesos y
la obligación de desinfectar por lo
menos seis veces al día
voluntarios y organizaciones sociales
han emitido una serie de sugerencias
para las trabajadoras sexuales como el
uso de gel anti bacterial cada media
hora y evitar el contacto cercano
durante la negociación con los clientes
y ya en el encuentro sexual evitar los
besos y procurar la máxima higiene
posible
[Música]
la crisis de el coronavirus también ha
afectado seriamente al sector de la
prostitución aquí en alemania que ha
permanecido cerrado durante meses este
hecho llevó a prostitutas en varias
ciudades de alemania a las calles a
protestar argumentando que los cierres y
las restricciones les estaban impidiendo
ganarse la vida e incluso las estaban
empujando hacia la clandestinidad en la
mayoría de estados federados de alemania
los locales continúan cerrados por
cuenta del virus aunque aquí en la
capital berlín por ejemplo ya se tomaron
primeras decisiones para relajar esas
restricciones a partir del mes de agosto
los burdeles pueden reabrir aunque no
están autorizados a ofrecer relaciones
sexuales es importante mencionar que la
prostitución en alemania es legal está
regulada y se estima que hay 40.000
personas registradas en este sector que
tienen derecho a contratos laborales y a
prestaciones sociales
[Música]